gordon's thing is working by the way i
can see it
yeah we should be recording now
great great
uh welcome welcome good people um good
evening again um
uh welcome to our pi data triangle uh
march event
um
i'm so glad um
everybody can join our online event and
i'll go ahead and start introducing our
uh presenter
gordon
uh
sorry gordon
how hot i'm so sorry uh okay uh how do
you pronounce your last name gordon just
heart like the organ
heart
great
thank you thank you for correcting me
um
yeah uh gordon has been
uh working with um
uh machine learning and big data for uh
years and uh according to her com i mean
according to some comment from gordon
after
being burned one too many times by
unexpected mission critical model
performance in production
gordon co-founded
kalina to build
a
machine learning testing and evaluation
prolap platform to tell you
what you need to know before your model
hits the real world
thank you gordon it's all yours thank
you
all right and thank you for that intro
young lady um
today i'll be presenting a presentation
called test centric ml model development
uh before we get into it i really want
to extend some thanks to dhruv and
everybody from pi data triangle for
having me on tonight i'm very happy to
be giving this talk and i'm hoping that
if you are training models this can
provide you with a little bit of
additional perspective and maybe help
you think about your problem in a
different way or if you're not training
models help you understand some of the
difficulties that come
from pushing models into production and
some of the ways that you might actually
successfully achieve some goals that you
have in that object
so i'll try to leave some time at the
end for questions and discussion uh but
without any further ado let's get into
this a little bit of an introduction who
i am why you should listen to me i've
built design built and deployed ai
products for dod and dhs customers uh
including the army air force marine
corps and then some dhs people like tsa
federal protective service and other
groups within that organization
uh i was the first engineer at a startup
called synapse that was acquired by
palantir building ml products for the
security domain
i worked there at palantir building ml
products and i co-founded kalenna as
john i mentioned where we're making a
machine learning testing and debugging
platform that is hopefully going to tell
you some things that you'd like to learn
before you have uh real results on the
line here so uh with a little bit of a
disclaimer uh these are slides adapted
from some pitch but i'll try to keep it
general interest and focus on the
problem and some sort of the general
things about what a solution might look
like and just spend a little bit of time
at the end talking about our particular
solution uh and in this focus on
designing and operationalizing ai
products here uh it's a bit of a
different perspective from one that you
might have as a researcher i'm focusing
particularly on actually getting results
and making sure that we're using this
technology effectively to achieve
whatever objectives you have there and
not just you know iterate better and get
higher higher and higher metrics on some
benchmarks
uh and in that process i think the main
thing that i've learned is that you
really can't trust ml to work as
expected
and to illustrate this let's look at a
case study where this is motivated from
some experience at synapse where our ml
team spent months improving the
statistical evaluation metrics for a
product that was trying to detect guns
in security x-ray scans things like what
you see on the right here uh this team
was getting better and better with their
models the amount of data that was going
into them was increasing quite rapidly
the model architecture was uh getting
more and more cutting edge in state of
the art uh
and our ability to accurately train our
models and tune our hyper parameters was
increasing as the team which was
maturing and our understanding of our
domain was as well uh and we get to this
point where we have a model with a 99 f1
score uh with 99.5 percent recall or
greater than that and less than 99
precision and so what this means if
you're not familiar with these metrics
is that with a 99.5 recall you would
expect only one in every 200 scans of a
gun to be missed by this model to not be
detected here and then uh we presented
these statistics to a customer
deployed this model out into the field
and the model missed a very obvious case
uh something that looks almost exactly
like what you see on the right where a
gun was just placed in the center of a
bin this is like a x-ray scanner that
you'll find at an airport or something
like that and so imagine those plastic
bins gun was just placed in the center
of the bin run through the machines it
goes through our system and sure enough
miss detection this is a single
occurrence that has pretty extreme
consequences for a mission critical ml
product uh you lose tr you lose trust
with your customer and lost trust is
irreparable uh to some extent there is
very very difficult time reestablishing
trust that you've lost by poor
performance and particularly by poor
performance that blindsided you
on our end this kicked off a long time
spent investigating why this happened
collecting additional data to make sure
that
we're training models for which this
wouldn't happen and then retraining
those models and validating that this
doesn't happen again and then
in our processes we collected all this
additional data and we made sure that it
was being used in training and those
samples were included in testing but
that whole process provides us with no
guarantee that this bug won't reappear
and as we're training models daily and
pushing new models out weekly uh
things like this silent regressions and
behavior are something that you really
need to be careful about
and
what this really comes down to is that
the current ml evaluation approach that
we have is falling short uh you'll spend
a lot of time collecting and annotating
data and you will
arbitrarily split that into some
training set validation set and then
test set that you finally use to produce
these metrics and so you train models
and they get better and better here
they're they trend closer and closer
towards zero loss and especially if you
have things that are getting up around
the 99 percent error area you are
succeeding in a lot of cases and failing
in relatively few cases here and you
keep iterating on your models you try
different architectures you try
different hyper parameters and you watch
these loss plots get better and better
and then you produce a global metric
like 99 f1 score that is produced by
performing inference on all of this uh
benchmark data set your test split there
you perform inference on that and
produce some global metric that says you
know we're 99 good at detection in this
case uh and that metric fails to tell
you really anything meaningful about the
model's behavior here and uh typically
since when you're iterating from one
model to the next you want to make sure
that you have uh you're comparing apples
to apples here you'll typically freeze
this benchmark data set you'll you know
set it at the beginning of the year and
then you'll do the next six months of
model development with the same frozen
benchmark and your main objective is
optimizing that global metric on that
frozen benchmark here and that really
fails to tell you anything about what
you can expect from your model in the
field
and one of the main reasons for that
is something that's been labeled by
research as the hidden stratification
problem in the past couple of years
and to understand what the hidden
stratification problem is uh let's look
at the specific case that motivated this
paper here where a researcher was trying
to reproduce some results from another
paper
uh trying to classify the presence or
absence of cancer in chest x-rays and he
was able to use the same model as the
other paper and reproduce the same
results here and uh you know get the
exact same numbers and it seemed like
that was uh you know a successful
reproduction of that paper but
when he looked into it as a researcher
he found that there were statistically
meaningful subclasses within the
main class of chest x-ray with or
without scan and so when you're training
this classifier you'd feed in this chest
x-ray and you are training against the
ground truth uh has cancer or doesn't
have cancer and you're training a
classifier model to try to discriminate
between images that do and do not have
cancer but that single label has cancer
has a lot of subclasses within it hidden
strata that are meaningful when it comes
to the predictive ability of the model
to accurately classify them and in this
particular case this researcher found
that
a majority of the successfully predicted
examples here these chest x-rays were
examples that had something called a
chest strain which is a
palliative procedure that's used to
reduce some of the symptoms of late
stage chest cancer and the model was
actually learning to use the presence of
a chest strain as a predictive indicator
and when he removed these scans with
chest strains you'll see here on this
receiver operating characteristic plot
over here that's plotting true positive
rate versus false positive rate as you
vary threshold is a very confidence
threshold uh and so something that looks
more like an l like an upside down l is
a better performer has a better ability
to uh accurately classify examples
the statistically the the meaningless
case the ones with chest strains where
the model was just looking at the
presence of a chest drain was very very
good it had generally quite good
performance the area under the roc curve
being 0.94 meaning it's getting close to
a perfect classifier there
the aggregate metric here was a little
bit less but still quite good you know
0.87 auc and the actually meaningful
case the one you care about in a
clinical setting the classification of
hazard has not cancer for images that do
not have chest strains was severely
underperforming here you have your auc
of 0.77 which means that this has very
little utility as a classifier and is
very far away from something that you
would expect to use in a clinical
setting here and this is a particularly
poignant example of the hidden
stratification problem but this exists
all over uh pretty much any domain that
you'll be trying to develop a model for
uh global metrics fail to capture the
full picture here this auc that you have
on all of these uh on all of the
examples aggregated doesn't actually
tell you what your performance in the
cases you care about is and typically
models will exhibit highly variable
performance across these different
subclasses
and since you're just looking at some
global metric here you can uh
improve greatly in one subclass that you
don't care about like the one with chest
drains and regress in one that uh you do
care about like no chest strains and
have that masked have that failure be
masked this regression be silent because
you're looking at only the average of
those subclasses
and this is a problem that exists across
the industry and
uh for the same reasons a lot of
important questions when it comes to
deploying models and trying to
successfully build ml products are
extremely difficult to answer if you've
been involved in this effort as an
engineer a scientist a pm an engineering
lead
a business person even a customer trying
to buy them
you have likely been on one end or maybe
both ends of these questions and seen
how difficult they can be to answer
basic things like what are the models
failure modes when can i expect it to
succeed if i'm pushing a new model what
has improved or what has regressed
if my model has improved by some you
know arbitrary delta in global metric
how how is this improvement distributed
is it can i expect better performance in
all scenarios or is it localized to a
particular scenario
if i have a certain deployment with
certain conditions and i have multiple
models maybe a couple of new models that
i've been training and some past models
that i've released which model is going
to be best for those circumstances which
model should we deploy and then the big
question which is very very difficult to
answer typically how do i know if my
model is ready to be deployed and this
is the scary one that you really like to
have a good answer for but often you
don't
the way that we solve this problem is
with a paradigm shift to something that
we call test case-based evaluation here
this is it involves a fundamentally
different way of thinking about your
problem uh it takes from a world where
we have a test set represented like what
we have on the left which might be
unbalanced across subclasses might be
arbitrarily split you know with our
train valve test split we'll take some
random sampling of this big bucket that
we're using to both train and evaluate
our models uh and we'll freeze this
benchmark data set and have you know
these different colors might represent
different subclasses we'll just have
those randomly scattered around in this
test set
and test case based evaluation involves
migrating to a world where you actually
sort those colors into different test
cases and you take your one benchmark
and break that benchmark data set into
many different more tightly scoped test
cases that are attempting to assess
behavior in a very specific scenario
here and when we're looking at the case
of the x-ray gun detector some of the
fine-grained test cases that we would
care about are things like gun in an
empty bin uh a top view maybe a front
view looking at the sensor or a back
view looking away from the sensor
guns in low occlusion environments guns
in high occlusion environments high blur
if you have an old or an uncalibrated
x-ray sensor
and these would be the sort of test
cases that you would be looking to
create in order to understand your
model's behavior
and when you create these test cases and
evaluate your models on them you get
high resolution test results here and to
illustrate that we'll look at this
example where we have two models labeled
model a and model b on the left and the
right we've produced a global metric on
our benchmark data set where model a is
97.8 let's say this is f1 score the
harmonic mean of precision and recall
but it could be anything you know
whatever metric you you use as your
north star as a team and model b has
99.2 on this global metric when we look
at this at the test case level here we
see that uh model a has quite good
performance across gun and empty bin
back view front view low occlusion and
very very poor performance in high
occlusion and high blur uh
model b on the other hand has middling
performance in gun and empty bin and
then good performance across back view
front view low occlusion and also pretty
good performance in high occlusion and
high blur but
all of these different scenarios don't
matter to your product equally
you should assign some product criteria
to them where we can say things like a
gun and empty bin is a critical behavior
that our product needs to have and when
you use that you can say based off of my
product criteria of this being a
critical example these others being
important and then these bottom two high
occlusion high blur being irrelevant
you can make the call that model a which
has the lower global metric is actually
better aligned with the objectives that
you're trying to achieve here and then
you can choose to deploy that model and
likely achieve better results in the
field
so the process here is something that we
call test centric ml model development
here where in in the middle of all of
the moving parties that are involved in
training and deploying ml models
the central item is your tests this
means that for your ml engineering team
uh the tests are what's used to guide
development and make sure that any
improvements in the models are
accurately reflected for the product
management team the tests are what
you're using to actually encode your
product objectives if you care about
behavior in a certain scenario you
reflect that with a test case of that
certain scenario and then you're able to
accurately assess whether or not you are
aligning with your objectives or not
and for bd and sales and external
parties tests are how you communicate
the behaviors and the capabilities of
your models here
and that's extremely important because
everything that you know about your
model behavior
before you push things to production you
learn from your tests uh this means that
if there is anything that you can expect
to see if there's any behavior or any
particular shortcoming that you might
have in your model the only way that
you'll surface that before you push
things into production and maybe get
burned is by good tests that will
uncover that
and what this means also is that your
testing data is more important than your
training data and this might seem
backwards to a lot of people that have
been thinking about ml or training ml
models because you obviously need more
training data or that's uh what the
current thinking is you need more
training data and then your testing data
should just be some small set that
validates learned behaviors from that
training example
uh that's backwards the training data is
ultimately an implementation detail the
training data if you have a model that
can acquire a certain set of behaviors
with 100 000 examples and a different
model that acquires that same set of
behaviors with a million examples
one of those isn't better than the other
necessarily because it used more or less
data
what matters is your ability to gain
these behaviors and uh as a developing a
product gaining the behaviors involves
um validating that the models that
you've produced actually have them here
and so your testing data sets the target
it says here's what i want and it gives
you something meaningful to iterate
towards and something meaningful to go
and collect more training data if that's
what you need to do
in our training in our testing data here
there are a lot of pitfalls that you can
fall into here blind spots can have
really unexpected consequences in this
example here uh that we have illustrated
on the right we have some class let's
say you know guns and security x-ray
scans uh distributed across different
subclasses a through f and these
subclasses might be things like
different occlusion levels or different
types of guns or something like that
what have you uh and we have our test
data distributed between those different
subclasses and uh the pink representing
our model's performance across these
different subclasses and
based on the model's performance
roughly you know being good in areas
that are represented highly in our data
set then this model actually looks like
a good model despite having extremely
deficient performance in subclass d and
the only reason this looks like a good
model is because we have a blind spot in
our data set we don't have subclass d
and that means that we can have very
poor performance in that particular
scenario and not have it surface to us
during the testing process and that's
extremely dangerous
even if you are to
put together a testing data set that is
evenly distributed you can still be
misled by the metrics that are produced
from it and here we have an example of
two models running on the same test data
where we have roughly even
representation uh across each of these
different subclasses a through f and so
our data set has probably been very
carefully put together it's been uh
manually curated to make sure that we're
representing each of these different
subclasses well
uh
model the model on the left
has relatively consistent performance
across each of the different subclasses
and the model on the right has extreme
spikes and extreme troughs in its
behavior it excels at subclasses e and f
and is quite deficient at subclasses a b
and c and both of these models can
produce the same global metric despite
having wildly different behaviors and
this is why looking at something that
says my f1 score on class x will never
tell you what you really need to know to
know you know can i deploy this model in
a deployment environment that's going to
see lots of subclasses a b and c you
just can't answer this question even if
you have a very very carefully put
together
test data set that has an even
distribution
it's important to say here sometimes it
feels
a little bit too
clear to say but it's important to
always reiterate that your metrics are
entirely dependent on the test data that
produces them these performance metrics
that you're producing are a function of
both the model and of the test data and
that means that uh you know when the
model is changing and when you're
reporting a metric with a new model the
only way that you can actually
understand what those metrics mean is if
you understand the data that backs it
and very very few people have a full
understanding of the data set that's
used to train these models i would say
that it's probably built in the head of
the ml engineer who's been leading that
particular training push uh if he or she
actually even has a full understanding
of what's in that test data set and how
it's distributed other people like
engineering managers or product managers
or business people or let alone
customers they don't have any of that
same context and so to them a
metric is just a number uh because they
have they're missing the context of what
that test data is and if you have one
model that produces a certain metric and
another model that produces another
metric you can report the improvement in
that metric you know to other people to
other stakeholders and they can see it
as a as a token that you're doing your
job that you're producing better models
but it doesn't tell them meaningful
things about you know what is this new
model that you're providing me is it
better at the things that i care about
uh is it going to cover some of the
failures that we've seen in the past
that metric fails to communicate that
and
another thing here is that quality
focused teams spend a lot of time right
now ensuring that their benchmarks are
evenly distributed uh because that
allows them to think about them more
more easily you don't have to think
about what some of the hidden biases in
your test data set are if it's
relatively evenly distributed across
subclasses you care about and it makes
the metrics more interpretable to
external parties because they don't need
to you know same thing build up that
state in their head of the distribution
of subclasses and you know an example
here would be if you have a
face recognition system you want that to
be roughly evenly split across some of
the important demographics that you care
about like age race and gender you want
to have an even representation of each
of the buckets that you've identified
there uh and even if you spend all this
time making sure that your benchmarks
are evenly distributed you still have
examples like this where you don't know
what the distribution of your failure
cases is within a given class you know
you can have all your subclasses
represented but you can still be misled
by the metrics that are produced on that
even data set
so
there is a better way here and those are
well-scoped unit test cases unit testing
is an approach that should be very
familiar to anybody who has written
software in the past you effectively
want to
write a very well scoped test that is
attempting to assert that a desired
behavior is present
at you know the smallest behavior at the
smallest level at the unit level here
and what this means for a ml model uh is
each of these different subclasses each
of these different scenarios could be
thought of as a unit a gun in an empty
bin on its side that would be a unit
that we'd want to test a revolver in a
very high occlusion scenario that would
be another unit and as uh you're
developing this product you'd want to
represent each of these scenarios that
you care about in your test data
prior to starting any training push here
you would want to get your tests up up
front and make sure that you have a
good representation of each of the
different
subclasses that you care about here
specking out the entire product's
desired behavior prior to training is
going to yield much better results the
ml team is going to know exactly what
they should be trying to build they're
going to know exactly what data they
need to go collect and annotate uh
product management knows exactly what to
expect and has the ability to say you
know we care about these scenarios and
we don't care about these scenarios and
effectively guide the thinking of the
engineers that are going to be doing
this training
and then lastly metrics uh themselves
don't communicate much
in general a metric of 95 96 versus one
of 98 99 that doesn't really tell you
anything uh it's not a meaningful piece
of information oh i went from 96 to 97.
uh and it encouraged teams to think
about reporting performance
qualitatively across each of these
different units that they're testing
here and up top we have an example of
some of the different bins that we want
to
drop performance into and the range and
the particular metric used here again f1
the and the ranges that you might use
for these buckets will change based off
of
the maturity of your models how good
they are your particular domain but in
general you should try to break it down
into some human understandable bins like
poor mediocre good very good and
excellent this tells you at a glance
here you have each of these different
units for these different test cases
you have their absolute performance and
you can of course report the metrics
here if anybody wants to see them you
have the absolute performance and you
know i'm mediocres in scenario c
only good in scenario f and very poor in
scenario g but i've got good behavior on
a b d and e and
that gives you at a glance you know sort
of an expectation of what you can see
from that model and if you report the
performance improvement or regression or
change in that metric from past
iterations of this model you can
communicate the behavior of a model in a
way that people that aren't ramped up on
the headspace of you know these exact
metrics or the exact training push or
the exact things that went into
improving this model people that don't
have that context or people that maybe
don't have that technical background can
still understand a report like this
which is telling them at a qualitative
level here's my absolute performance and
here's how this model got better or
regressed across this unit
talking about test centric ml model
development i think it's important to
ground us in the traditional ml model
development cycle here which we have
diagrammed this is an intentionally
constrained view of the world that
allows you to focus more closely on
model training and treat uh
the actual production of the models as
something that's downstream from the
business people and putting in their
business inputs here uh this is the way
that you would try to make a model if
you were operating in a research lab
maybe without the business inputs that
would probably be a
you know research goals would go there
and data engineering would maybe be an
open source data set or some data set
that you get as a part of the grant and
model monitoring you probably would have
model reporting there rather than model
monitoring but this sort of process here
where data is flowing pretty much one
way all of your data is collected up
front there's a lot of iteration on
model training and a lot of fine-tuning
there this is the old view of the world
which uh it will give it will train you
models that have all sorts of unexpected
uh gaps in their behavior
training centric ml is i think a
byproduct of the types of people that
have been training models frankly
there's mostly it's ml engineers or ml
scientists or data scientists and they
are bringing a research mindset to it
this is a relatively nascent field uh
there's been a lot of hype for it in the
last 10 years and it's exploded
commercially because companies feel like
they need to be having ml teams and you
know building ml products uh and only
recently have we gotten to the point
where i would say that the model
architectures that can successfully
achieve objectives are not iterating as
quickly as they were five years ago the
approaches to successful model training
are stabilizing somewhat there's lots of
tools both open source and proprietary
that you can find for each of the
different steps along the model
development pro
pipeline and at this point it's becoming
something that is less of a research
discipline and more of an engineering
discipline
and productionizing ml is pretty
different from lab based research ml
here and i want to talk here about what
we call a test centric ml model
development flow where the center line
you know these purple arrows are all
about how we can test our model our
tests being the central uh if i go back
to a previous slide here
are tests being the central part of the
nl model development process everything
that we do is mediated through our tests
here and when we have this
test centric ml model development flow
we start from our objectives and the
first thing that we do is we try to
define the actual product specifications
uh this is an important exercise for us
to go through because a specification
like i want a gun detector that can
detect every gun that is an unreasonable
specification what different makes of
guns what different scanners are you
going to support what different level of
occlusions are you going to support do
you want it to be able to do you want to
focus primarily on cases that humans
are deficient at you know if you're
trying to make something that's an
operator assist system uh what levels of
assembly are you going to go for is it
only fully assembled guns does that
include loaded guns what about
ammunition and magazines each of these
questions are things that you can plug
your ears and sort of la la la away and
push that onto your ml team to try to
figure out uh but that doesn't help you
build successful products here and so
the test centric ml model development
flow shifts that responsibility for
defining the success criteria to product
managers and this is pretty critically
important because they need to get their
hands dirty and they need to look at
data and define tests
the tests function as the product
specification here i've said this before
earlier on and i'll say it again
your expectations for the behaviors that
you want to see in the field need to be
represented in tests that's the only way
that you can know that your models are
or are not succeeding in those
circumstances and so the tests that you
put together they are the functional
encoding of your product specification
here and once you have that encoding of
your product specification you can have
this model training flow over here which
involves all of the collection and
assembly of training data perhaps you're
tweaking it you're going and gathering
more you're getting better annotations
all of that process is actually off of
the central path here of the test-based
test centric ml model development flow
here you can train your models improve
your data iterate as much as you want
and just keep assessing yourself against
this central specification testing your
performance against that central
specification and anything that better
aligns with that specification moves on
to production here and that's where you
start to see products that are actually
succeeding in the things that they were
designed to do and having you know felt
impact in the world
another big part of this whole flow is
that
in production you'll always observe bugs
and
observing a bug is something that
shouldn't just go and become a new thing
like if you shouldn't short-circuit the
observation of a bug up here and back
into assembling training data and then
training models and then go back into
testing your model and then pushing that
out into production
a bug that's observed needs to be
reproduced the same way that you
wouldn't go and
get a bug filed for your software
product and then go and write the code
change and then
open a pr
the first thing that you do is you
reproduce that bug you know does it
exist as it was reported uh how did how
is it presenting and what circumstances
is it presenting in what circumstances
is absent that sort of reproduction
process is exactly what you'd want to do
for an ml product you'd observe the bug
you create a test case for it and you'd
put that back into your tests
and you'd use that to better guide the
models that you would want to deploy
into the field here
one of the things that i want to mention
here as well as we're when we're on this
slide i want to call out test driven
design a little bit in software
engineering uh it can be a contentious
topic i think that a lot of people have
had good experiences with tdd and a lot
of people have had bad experiences with
tdd and
sort of the reasons that it's either
good or bad or uh they don't necessarily
apply to the ml
domain here a lot of the difficulty in
tdd is coming up with defining
interfaces that are easily testable
or getting yourself very deep into the
muck with mocks uh and in ml
the same considerations don't really
apply you just need to be able to
make sure that your desired behaviors
are represented in tests
because that is the only way that you
can actually verify the presence of the
behavior you can't spin up the app
locally and click around a little bit
and follow the right path and make sure
that you have uh implemented the feature
properly you need to create tests
because it's the only way that you can
verify your problem
uh in software your options are write
tests up front right tests after the
facts or rely on manual testing and all
of those have their
position where they're useful uh
but that's not exact those aren't your
options for ml your options are pretty
much set up rigorous tests up front uh
or cross your fingers and if you cross
your fingers what you'll end up doing is
either setting up rigorous tests after
the fact and wishing that you've done it
up front or failing to build a
successful product and that's the
unfortunate reality for a lot of teams
that have
attempted to build ambitious ml products
in the last couple of years
this process of finding a bug and
creating a test case from it and feeding
that back into your tests is something
that we might call regression testing
for machine learning regression testing
allows you to fix a bug one time and
make sure that that bug doesn't become
unsquashed at some point in the future
here uh you know as we talked about
earlier you might have a new model that
has better performance in certain
scenarios and poor performance in some
previous scenarios that were bug
scenarios and you might have that
regression masked by those improvements
in other scenarios here and you might
silently lose that behavior if you don't
have a well-scoped regression test in
regression test suite
uh regression test suites are
effectively necessary in efforts to
chase down the long tail during training
most domains i would say are
characterized by a lot of common
examples and then common and similar
examples and then a very long tale of
examples that get increasingly uncommon
and increasingly disparate in
presentation uh called the long tail and
the long tail problem is ever is what
autonomous vehicle companies are coming
up against most of them have good models
that work well in most circumstances but
there is a very long tail of all
different sorts of circumstances that
they need to make sure they uh perform
well in here and
creating regression tests and
making sure that you cover this space is
more or less the only way that you can
keep your ml team from looking like
these kids and playing whack-a-mole
where you smack a bug and then you turn
around you turn back around and it's
back uh and that process can be
exhausting it's fun if your age is four
plus and you play it for 15 minutes but
it is exhausting if you're trying to do
that and building an actual ml product
out of it
regression tests as well if we go back
to the previous slide
help
move us from a world of a more waterfall
based
ml development process where we decide
what we want to do we collect a bunch of
data we train and then we deploy that
model and that you know is maybe a
couple month process to a more agile
process where as long as we have
something that's doing better on our
tests we can push that model
that's something that i think is very
important agile software development
allows teams to operate much more
effectively there's a lot less
management overhead once you set up the
processes and it generally gets better
features to customers quicker than
something waterfall based
right now we're still in the waterfall
world in most teams for ml development
but when you have a central
model performance test suite that you
can use you can start thinking about
ways that you can automate that process
here
and
automating that process probably
involves using some global metric that
you want to
when a new model is better on that
global metric you can push that new
model out into the field and i'll say
here global metrics are not all bad
global metrics like f1 score are tend to
be bad they tend to be misleading but
there are certain ways that you can
arrange them
where they make sense and they actually
assess your ability to uh succeed in the
scenarios in which you do need to
succeed here and so if you need a global
metric it should look something like
this
an objective function here that's just a
sum of each of the different scenarios
represented by some performance and here
is where we might have something like f1
plugged in and some scalar value that
we've assigned to that scenario how
important is success in this scenario to
us building a successful product here
and when you define an objective
function like this you can say i care
very much about going an empty bin
okay i care quite much about back view
front below occlusion and i don't really
care about high occlusion and high blur
this allows you to build automated
systems where those model a and model b
that we saw uh earlier in the
presentation are actually evaluated
against the degree to which they match
up with your goals here and model b was
the one that had the 99 global metric
and model a had 97
but when we see that we break it down
with these scenarios and we assign
product values to these different
scenarios you know proportional to how
much we actually care about them then it
becomes very clear that model a is the
better model and you can use processes
like this to set up cd systems where you
develop a new model you run it across
all your tests you generate your
objective function value here and if
that's better than your current golden
model that's in prod then you kick that
one out and you push this new model out
into production here and if the idea of
pushing
new models to production without any
human decision in the loop scares you i
would say you should think about ways
that you can actually
quantify what you care about break it
into test cases and assign values to
those and in the ideal world you will
have the ability to say i care about
these cases this much and if your
objective function doesn't align well
with uh you know what you actually care
about then your work shouldn't be
ripping out the cd system it should be
making sure that you have the right test
cases and you have the right values
assigned to them
there's odds are uh somebody within an
organization making ml products has
something like an informal product value
an informal objective function they have
these weights in their head uh and
they're going to be making the call can
we or can we not um
deploy this model here and this is a
very simple scenario here we just have a
linear sum but you know if you care
about things like bias you can do things
like variants across test cases that are
broken down by race gender and age
if there's a high variance there then
you can penalize that for your model and
say that we only want models that are
generally pretty consistent across each
of these different important subsets of
our of our data
hey gordon yes
start to interrupt is it okay um if
someone asks you several you know some
questions while you're presenting
yeah absolutely uh sorry i can't see
anybody and and nothing no i'll do the
answer i'll do the reading part no
worries um so there was a question
popping up from matt phillips
matt was saying um
i'm having a hard time understanding how
machine learning is supposed to fix or
handle the bugs for example i think
that's your one of your previous slides
where you are having the test
centralized graph yeah right here
um so uh matt was asking uh the machine
learning tests are model performance
tests aren't they
uh but the bug fixing is a different set
of tests is that right
yeah so uh what i would say here is that
just to be clear what we mean by a bug
is a particular deficiency in model
performance in some scenarios so uh a
model's tendency to fail to detect a
handgun alone in a bin for example could
be a behavioral bug and this is sort of
what we're what we're talking about here
where you would then create a test case
with a number of examples of a gun alone
in a bin and you would use that you'd
run your current model on that and
verify that yes you do have poor
performance in that scenario and you
would use that uh test case as the pro
the proof that the bug exists currently
and for the next iteration the proof
that that bug is squashed and for all
subsequent iterations as a part of your
regression test suite as long as you
stay green on that particular test case
that regression test with all guns alone
in the bin you would know that you're
not regressing on that particular area
and that you you haven't reintroduced
this bug
does that answer your question
yeah matt uh feel free to unmute
yourself if you would like to say some
comments yeah
i think i remember from the uh uh
intro literature that you have your own
company can i just suggest that you find
a different word um bug means something
to anybody who's done done software
engineering bug means something you know
very different and pretty concrete and
some i mean somebody who does both uh
quite quite different from uh from a
model a model performance defect right i
mean having weights you know within a
model not where you want them to be is
something very very different from you
know for getting a semicolon
or uh or you know anything else that
goes by the name of bug right and so
it's just gonna create enormous
confusion when engineers and scientists
work together if you start calling
prediction deficiencies bugs so just a
friendly friendly suggestion
for us
yeah that's quite helpful and we've also
heard that using things like test cases
uh can be confusing for people that are
coming to things with a software
perspective
and it's definitely good for us to
maintain a focus on using language that
people don't come with all of their
preconceived notions about
any other questions
um i think uh we have it right now
feel free to
yeah this is true
i have a no it's more of an observation
so uh if you can go back to the slide
where you're maximizing for cixa yes
yeah this is uh like i don't know like
from
like looking at it from a finance
perspective right like this is or
anything else this is just maximization
of expected utility um if you can open
that uh like wikipedia wikipedia page i
think it's the exact same formula there
and this is why i find this approach an
extremely extremely useful
approach because kind of ties in the
idea of utility back into the world of
machine learning performance which which
i think is a big miss in the industry
right now which is huge
yeah i really appreciate that that
comment here drew thanks for saying that
and one of the interesting things that
we've seen is
uh teams have also found ways to plug
their kpis into this model objective
function and use that directly like how
much money are we making per you know
gpu minute that we spend running this
model things like that especially
companies that can quantify their return
on their investment into their ml
processes uh companies like that can put
together something that is very very
connected to reality as their utility
function for their models and that's you
know quite interesting for us to see
great and a good good conversation uh
please um again please feel free to
unmute yourself if uh uh hopefully
gordon you don't mind um uh
you know this is more um interactive
session if you would say
yeah absolutely definitely feel free to
interrupt me and i'm gonna hopefully
blow through the rest of these slides
and leave some uh time for questions at
the end or you can interrupt me in the
middle or at the end of any slide
so another thing that you can do to make
sure that
your training models that are succeeding
is test model robustness by using
augmentations here augmentations are a
very very common practice for people to
use in training but they're not that
common to use in testing uh they're ways
to make a smaller data set feel larger
and you should be
pretty careful about uh trying to learn
too much from your augmentations or
relying too heavily on them they're
certainly not a panacea but they can be
quite useful for doing things like
assessing your model's robustness to
perturbations to the inputs or
degradations to the inputs here and so
you can do things like perform an
investigation into differing different
lightness levels you can artificially
lower the brightness of a lot of images
and see how your model's performance
drops off as you get closer and closer
to
zero for all of these pixel values if
you're making a uh something that uses
faces you can apply targeted cutouts to
remove interesting features here uh
remove perhaps important features like
the mouth or the eyes and see how much
your model is relying on those
particular features or how much it's
able to uh fall back on additional
features when those are absent and that
might do a good job of telling you
things like how well does my model
perform when people are wearing opaque
sunglasses if you don't have a lot of
examples of that one of the things one
of the ways you can easily gather those
examples or uh you know make mocks of
them is with these uh targeted cutouts
and same thing for the face it might be
a person that's drinking from a cup or
something like that might have their
mouth occluded and this is a good way
for you to mock that
and so that's another interesting way
that you can
improve your ability to test your
model's robustness
and another way
method of testing that you would be
pretty interested in
as a team that's deploying models is
something like integration testing using
the exact deployment conditions that
you'd be seeing
often we have models that are trained in
something like pi torx locally and
they're running on gpus they're using
32-bit floating points and the
deployment conditions for those models
differ significantly you know maybe you
are packaging it for a completely
different run time like on nx maybe
you're quantizing it taking all your
weights from 32-bit floating point and
flattening them into 8-bit integers such
that your model size is smaller and that
it runs faster on hardware that isn't
float optimized a lot of these
techniques are used for particularly
edge devices including your phone
or if you need to run a model at extreme
scale and you can't just afford an
unlimited fleet of v100s in aws
uh so this is something integration
testing with these actual final
packaging can surface some pretty
important uh losses in behavior when
you're performing these packagings and
there might also be meaningful
differences in pre or post-processing
most for example in computer vision most
models can't just take an arbitrarily
sized input
they have a fixed size input and you
will either crop your image into tiles
with maybe some overlap maybe not or you
would resize your image to fit into the
fixed size of the model uh this is you
know if you have a security camera that
is producing like let's say 640 by 480
low resolution uh images and your model
was trained on images of all different
sorts of resolution
crunching additional metrics and
performing integration tests with images
that are only the size that you expect
to see in deployment is a very important
thing for you to tell to tell you what
you might expect to see here
uh and another case would be the the
shifts in data distribution between your
development and your deployment
environment here if we look at the x-ray
security case um
you have certain things that are
relatively low criticality like water
bottles occurring with an extremely high
frequency and uh extremely critical
things like guns and explosives
occurring almost never here and you
might want to run integration tests with
uh images that are more representative
of the stream of commerce and that means
that you know maybe one image and 10
million is going to have a gun in it
and
integration tests like that will give
you a much better feel for what it's
like to actually use your product you
know if i'm an operator and i'm using
this operator assist product for a week
how many uh you know chicken little type
false positive detections on guns and
explosives am i going to see if i see
one a day you know maybe that's
acceptable maybe i still trust the
product if i see one every hour my trust
and my ability to think that the
detections being produced by the system
or quality is going to drop off quite
dramatically because i know that this is
a relatively infrequent class
but clearly this model is seeing it
everywhere and so those are all
important things that you might want to
test in integration
of course your efforts to understand
behavior can't stop at testing to use
another case study here we're looking at
a technique called saliency mapping that
attempts to produce a heat map like this
you can render it as a heat map that
tells you how much each pixel in the
image contributed to the output
detection here
and when we performed this on uh guns
and night gun and knife imagery we found
that one of the most salient features
for a lot of fixed blade knives was this
partial tang here this little piece of
the blade that sticks into the handle
and knives that did not have the partial
tang like full tang knives where the
blade extends all the way through the
handle are generally much higher quality
knives uh we were performing much much
worse on them despite them showing up
[Music]
much more clearly in x-ray which renders
metal as blue and much more visible and
when we kicked off this investigation we
learned that uh we were using the
partial tang as a predictive feature
because we got knives from all different
sorts of places they looked different
but under x-ray they had one thing in
common which was that they were all very
cheap knives that we sourced from
overseas and the manufacturers cut
corners there and the majority of them
were partial tang knives that didn't
have you know more expensive features
like full tank here
uh and the same thing went with with
handguns we found that the trigger
assembly is something that is a key
predictive feature and when you occlude
the trigger assembly or artificially cut
it out or remove it from the gun itself
then the model's ability to detect it
was
significantly diminished and uh opening
up the black box methods are a good way
to supplement the understanding that you
get from
something like a test case-based
valuation approach here
uh rigorous testing is not easy uh you
know we've outlined a lot of problems
and a lot of ways to solve them but one
of the things that a lot of those
solutions
share is that it's quite difficult to
implement they're tedious time consuming
hard to manage at scale
but the way that you produce models is
by putting in the effort to improve your
processes putting in the short term
effort for compounding effects
and
we have made kalenna to give you a
platform to do exactly that uh help you
make more robust ml testing i'm just
going to blow through these so we get to
the questions here part of that is
analysis and comparison tools single
model views and multi-model comparison
views threshold tuning to make sure that
you're deploying with the exact values
that you need for your deployment
conditions surfacing and debugging
failure modes uh viewing individual
predictions in any degree of detail
automatically surfacing commonalities
among images in your failure cases
creating and curating high resolution
test cases searching through your image
data with the natural language interface
to pick out images like this one with
car parked on the city street and use
that to make test cases with hundreds of
thousands of examples in minutes
automatically curating ground truths in
platform such that you don't have to
keep looking at noise and you can remove
them without disruption
and then integrating into your existing
testing pipelines uh with our python
client that you can use to automate your
testing deployment and test creation
here of course this uh wouldn't be
possible at all without open source uh
it goes without saying but i really want
to make sure that it doesn't go unsaid
here that the python open source
community is truly outstanding uh and
they are a foundation point of
everything that we and other teams do
here and if you uh you know work on or
contribute or support in any way or you
can come to meetings like this thank you
very much from us from the bottoms of
our heart
particularly if you've worked on the pi
data sphinx team sphynx theme which is
what we use to render our documentation
which you might have noticed over here
if you've got a sharp eye
there are just so many amazing tools
here that really make it
able make us able to build kind of
amazing products relatively quickly and
have a amazing community to fall back on
uh and a very open one that we can
contribute patches to as necessary work
with authors to make sure that gaps are
covered really quickly
and upstream our changes to make sure
that everyone's benefiting from the work
that we're putting in to improve these
libraries
so thank you everybody for listening um
i don't know how i did my time here
because we started a little bit late but
if we have any time with questions uh
for questions i would love to field some
right now
yes um thank you gordon for
this awesome presentation uh we do have
one question from mark uh breuch
has anyone encountered the following you
know institution how would you
explain
you know model inference result on gpu
not equal to
model inference on gpu uh on the same
system
uh glad to you know uh i had an
integration test to spot it but what is
the cost
uh mark could you uh i mute yourself if
i did not see that correctly yeah
thanks for reading it out thank you
appreciate that
so this is definitely something that can
happen uh especially if you're running
on a different engine or you're
packaging your model but it sounds like
in this case it was just the same engine
but either gpu or cpu and if you see
differences in performance there it i
would say it's most likely to be a
different float handling
in the gpu and in whatever float
processor you have in your cpu here
there are lots of edge cases with floats
and not all
silicon implements the exact same
strategy and
float error tends to add up as you
perform lots of these computations and
so if you have a model uh that is maybe
100 or more layers and in each of those
layers you've got thousands and
thousands of neurons the floats that
you're uh that you're multiplying
together and then adding together
it is very very possible that small
changes in the implementation between
these different hardwares uh led to
substantive differences in uh
predictions
thanks thanks gordon for the response
appreciate that
how
what's what's the fix though distill the
model onto the deployment hardware
yeah the fix would definitely be to make
sure that anything that you know that
you can't fail on you're testing in as
close to deployment conditions as
possible here you know typically you
wouldn't i wouldn't expect to see huge
differences
across cpu or gpu or different gpus um
and i don't know if you saw just maybe
one that flipped another direction one
that you know was a success and is now a
failure maybe the other way around but
the way that you would minimize that is
by making sure that the testing that
matters a lot is happening in that
integration stage where you have the
exact code that you're going to use to
run it the exact runtime the exact
hardware and you use those numbers as
the ones that are the most trustworthy
and everything else has some sort of
lossy indicator maybe of what things
will look like actually in deployment
thank you gordon i mean i'm yet to
evaluate the magnitude of the problem
that's interesting to hear about though
thank you for sharing that
yeah thank you gordon um
james mannis was wondering if you could
drop off i mean drop your email address
in the chat um
james must have some
um
uh
you know willingness to connect with you
um
yeah absolutely i'll post that there and
thank you for the reminder james i want
to do put a plug here we are hiring for
front-end back-end uh ml engineering
roles uh and anybody if they think that
they could contribute to an early stage
seed stage product like this uh we would
love to talk to you more and even if
it's just an informal chat you know so
that we can get a better understanding
of each other uh i would love for you to
reach out to me and i'll send my email
in the chat here
right let me see if i can stop sir i do
have
yeah i do have a
quick quick question guys but a couple
of them actually so first of all thank
you uh gordon for taking taking my offer
up on this uh this has been a really
nice talk and
i hope the community liked it as well
and i would love the community to also
um
speak out if you have seen these
problems if you if you can relate with
these problems i as a team lead i think
most of my time is actually
you know spent
on getting the business to crystallize
the success metrics and most of the
times that is the hardest thing to do
because nobody really knows what success
is especially early on in the research
project so that has been my pain point
and i think this this framework this
thought framework as well helps with
that um early on in the game
uh personally but i would love to know
what the community thinks the second
question second part to this thing is
how do you handle drift um and like how
do you quantify drift in these test
cases because
if the data drifts too soon um then the
test case is that the work of creating
those test cases kind of
changes
how do you propose handling that
scenario
when we'll stop there
yeah i can uh leave it up to the
community right now if they want to
answer that first one or i'll hop on the
second one if nobody wants to jump in
cool so about uh data drift all i can
say is that uh the last thing that you
want to do is sort of put together
perfect tests and then imagine that
they're perfect and that nothing ever
needs to change as you said data drifts
your understanding of your own domain
changes your ability to collect and
successfully annotate data evolves as
you mature into a project and the
tools that you might be using also
change you know you might be able to
later on more effectively uh find a lot
of examples that are interesting to you
in ways that you couldn't do early on
and you know all of these things
contribute towards the general
recommendation that you never freeze
anything um you should be constantly
updating your tests to be as close to
your understanding of your product
objectives as possible and uh that
involves you know are in a platform in a
test case management platform you should
have the ability to version all your
tests and that test case platform should
be the one that's figuring out if i want
to compare this new model that was run
on these new versions of these tests
against this old model that was around
on these old versions it should be able
to figure out what the shared examples
in those test cases are and compile your
metrics against only that shared set uh
you really shouldn't get into a point
where you're like oh you know i just
don't want to change my data set because
i don't want to lose the ability to
meaningfully compare against past models
or you don't want to say okay now is the
time that i'm changing my data set
goodbye to any sort of historical
tracking
that's really just a data management
platform a data management problem and
it should be solved by a testing
platform
also is this is this work
available open source or like how how is
the platform being uh
proposed
yeah it's it's an enterprise product uh
we're looking to launch a freemium
version of it uh and with that we would
also um open source our client um but it
is
uh as you can imagine something that's
changing a lot right now uh and
relatively early and so all of that is
probably i would say at a minimum a year
18 months away uh but it's on our it's
on our radar we definitely want to make
sure that we can get this in the hands
of people uh that need good testing and
that you know don't necessarily have the
ability to sign an enterprise contract
sounds great
so actually i want to this is matt
phillips um one to ask
maybe give an excuse to plug the product
some more because i feel like as talk
was really interesting i like that
starting thinking about things from a
testing case first right machine
learning is maybe mature enough now that
that maybe this you can start to do this
you can turn it into a big software
engineering problem essentially or kind
of take the same kind of mindset but
it's like well i've heard your talk i
saw that i saw that nice flow chart but
how does any particular product help how
is any product going to be actually
worth it to me to like even learn even
it was free right as opposed to just
kind of absorbing the philosophy saying
you know thanks
and and then thinking about how i can
you know
come up with a more test centric
approach and sort of you know focus in
and talk more with business people or
the business side and and
and establish these test cases earlier
like like how like i can do all that you
know just
by myself right how does how does your
product like actually add
which is
but but you know take this as an excuse
to just plug cl
more
yeah it's a great question matt i
appreciate you asking it if the only
thing that you get is this general idea
of what good testing looks like and you
know you keep that in the back your mind
then i think this is a success uh you
certainly don't need to you know
immediately be jumping to use our
product or a similar one after this talk
but you know that being said i think
that the big question that we get from a
lot of people is like yeah this is great
uh it seems like a lot of work to set up
and a platform i think can offer two
main differentiators there one of them
being a bit what i was talking about
earlier uh the management of these test
cases and the data problem of figuring
out i have this old model i have this
new model
give me an apples-to-apples comparison
between them if they've been trained on
extremely different sets of data that is
a pretty big important piece
to
allow you to decouple your model
training and your uh test evolution from
your you know ability to generate
meaningful reports and meaningful deltas
as you move forward as a team uh but the
that's just a software engineering
problem really um the second main thing
that a platform offers is the tools to
create these test cases if you have a
lot of images and you uh are very likely
only annotating them for the things that
you're actually training your model on
you're probably not paying teams to add
annotations that are non-critical like
non-critical metadata uh and
that is an expensive process and it's
something that most teams are not doing
some of them are and some teams are
doing things like training classifiers
to automatically enrich their data with
these
metadata tags but that's something that
is very much an afterthought and a
testing platform can provide you with
tools to actually create those tests
relatively quickly here i think that
there are a number of technologies that
particularly for images are reaching
maturity uh such as like image
similarity search where you can uh
pretty quickly and pretty effectively
surface images with similar features and
you can do the same thing uh to build a
natural language search interface where
like i demoed it for a very brief amount
of time uh on the presentation where you
can actually take a embedding take a
take a take a phrase let's say like a
photo of a car on the side of the street
and map that into the same embedding
space as a bunch of embeddings that
you've extracted from images and you can
just find embeddings that are similar to
that new embedding from your text query
and use that to actually search through
your data in a natural language way
and this is how you get a data set
that's you know a million or more images
and that's how you effectively cut
through it and make these fine-grained
test cases and that tooling is not easy
to develop uh it's very labor-intensive
and it involves a lot of
pretty pretty tight focus i would say on
uh you know the the ux of searching
through data and creating test cases
from it and i would say that that's one
of the main value adds really that you
get from a dedicated testing platform
that would be very difficult to roll
yourself
okay uh thanks a lot
all right
great uh conversations i like it um
thank you so much again gordon for the
awesome
presentation uh we kind of short on time
um let's go ahead and
skip my slides
no worries guys um
so
still we need to introduce us uh again
so gus is a um recovering consultant
that led to soft uh development
yeah actually sorry could i could i jump
on that quickly i'm
not a software not a consultant
i previously worked at some dc area
consultant consultancies
yeah i've been in software the software
business for a while now so similar to
to garden
um i worked at a company called anaconda
which maybe the pi data community is
familiar with and i met somebody there
named matt rocklin who created an open
source project called dasc and dasc is
great for scaling up workloads
python code from your local machine to a
cluster and back
and i give as one of the many you know
one people he then started a company to
provide an enterprise version of desk
which i would love hopefully someone
could ask at the end like why would i
pay for some enterprise version of desk
what i can't do myself um but mostly
what i'm here to do now is just
evangelize a little bit around desk
itself
and i will show a slide or two and then
i'm going to jump into some demos and
hopefully we have a little bit of fun
and i will keep this i'm going to try to
do this in 15 minutes so i'm going to go
really fast but if you can see my slide
can you see my screen really quickly let
me verify given my embarrassing foray
early yeah um yes we can see your slice
now yeah perfect perfect so i think let
me just jump in this is kind of the
world that we know i made this graph up
right but there's lots of data and if
you have python on your local machine
you can process it with pandas with
numpy with just writing python code
das comes in because it will help you
scale up vertically to all of the cores
on your local machine so you have a
pandas data frame it works on a single
core
you want to use all of those cores you
import desk we'll show you how to do
that and scale up to all the cores on
your machine if your local machine has
gpu cards like you've got a tesla v100
you can use das and it will scale up to
all of those gpus it's really nice you
can also scale out to clusters and i'll
show you a fun example of that in a
second
but most importantly and this will be
the main theme of my talk here is that
when you have existing python code you
don't have to reinvent the wheel and i
what i mean by that is if someone's
written scientific code to do something
and so you may be maybe it's testing but
maybe more likely it's some sort of
numerical calculation you can dascify it
and you can run it across a big cluster
very unscientific but it can be very
very effective
so uh for those unfamiliar and i'll jump
into slideshow mode for a second this is
a quick you know there's a fun little
graphic of das but here's the core idea
if you're used to using things like
pandas numpy import pandas pd read your
csv it looks exactly the same in das you
get a high level interface arrays uh
data frames psychic learning cell
estimators for scaling things out sure
there can be problems along the way when
you scale a bit when you get to big
scale but this is the interface that
people like and you'll we'll see a split
and it's a growing community of people
who'll say i'll try dask versus
something like spark which is your
standard big data processing tool
with das you can run it on your laptop
hit or con to install it it works really
nicely when you have a machine with lots
of cores or gpus it also runs on
clusters and we'll cover and very i'll
just jump into demos you can see all
three of these
but before i do very very important if
you're going to scale things up you're
going to run on a cluster or and you're
going to use desk you should know when
not to use it there are a couple of key
things you should probably do first if
you're being if you're following a good
software engineering practice or a good
scientific practice use better
algorithms like maybe there's a way in
numpy or pandas to do what you want to
do without going to desk maybe you can
use a better file format like tsar or
netcdf or parquet maybe you can compile
your code with psython or numba if
you're not aware of those tools number
for one is really cool just in time
compile tool you can always sample or
sometimes you can sample
and then you can also profile your code
and look for where the bottlenecks are
before you scale it
but i pause it to you all today
to not do those things instead we are
going to take the equivalent of gripping
it and ripping it so grab your code
get a cluster or use all the cores in
your local machine let's just scale the
heck out of this thing
okay so enough of this
can you see my terminal now is that can
you see my shell
this is so embarrassing if you can't
we're still on the okay
then we're going to jump we're going to
jump right into the dashboard so here's
here's a typical here's a calculation
just generic scientific workload i'm
running i'm running this on a cluster
it's a dash cluster this cluster is
composed of four machines each of these
have two workers a piece and this thing
is plotting along so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to scale up the number
of workers here i'm just going to scale
this up really quickly
and this cluster will respond in a
second you can see it starting to plod
here
this cluster will accept the new workers
as they're provisioned these will be vms
in my case from a cloud provider but
where however i've deployed desk it
doesn't matter this could be
10
virtual cores on my laptop on my my vm
and i have 100 available
these as these additional resources are
added to the cluster das will just
automatically start applying the
computation to them it'll take about a
minute here and we'll see this go much
much faster
so a core idea of das being you know we
can be scientific we can be clever we
can figure out how to make things run or
we can simply scale the work that we're
doing and when these workers get added
here please go ahead and add to my to my
cluster please pretty please
you'll see these come online and this
competition is gonna is gonna speed up
i'm gonna give this one more deep breath
and then i'm going to move on sorry
come on come on machines don't embarrass
me
let's see okay
with that we're going to in the use of
time we're going to keep this thing
moving so
let me show you a really quick example
of desk locally and this is how most of
you will use it so i'm going to create a
simple numpy style array and when i
visualize this desk has this nice oh my
goodness how beautiful here
lovely what a great great start to my
demo um
let me install this really quickly
actually you know what no i'm not going
to do that we're just going to jump in
we're going to jump to the big example
um
so i'm going to show you desk on a
cluster here
so when you work with desk you'll
typically just import dash array or dash
data frame you can go forth and do do
whatever you'd like you have the option
and it's it's a very nice one of running
a local cluster and actually let me just
show you what this looks like so when i
run or when i choose to run i'll open up
a new notebook here
from
copy this cell over
desk gives you this very nice option of
running something called a local cluster
and let's just take a look at what that
is and what that means
this means
that i have access to i can see what i'm
running on my local machine or and soon
we'll see in a second running on a
cluster of machines but the idea being
that
i can profile and i get this wonderful
dashboard for understanding what's going
on so with my local client here i have
access to 12 threads for
logical cores and 16 gigs of memory and
that's nice and now i can do stuff i can
import fast data frame i could run
through this the simple desk array
example here and i can start to run
operations like
adding things together i can
transpose whatever the standard stuff i
would do behind the scenes das is going
to build a task graph for me it's going
to in theory at least and hopefully in
reality for most users it's going to
hide the complexity of all this and when
you do something like a dot product
das will be building a task graph behind
the scenes to execute this code in
parallel even when it isn't really that
parallel when it's not embarrassing
when there are lots of things that need
to connect to each other in a non-linear
fashion das will handle that logic
that's the core of what it does
and so as you start to build more
complex operations your code is going to
look like standard numpy pandas code and
das will be building relatively complex
graphs behind the scenes
so then when we do things like actually
have some sort of standard for loop or
python style code here go ahead and
import das
if i go through and run this and execute
this code it will execute serially so in
my case
let me jump this over really quickly
into a simple interface make this a
little bit bigger
we'll execute this these functions inc
double add
some of these could be run in parallel
but by default python's going to execute
this one by one
and so when i run this with
desk i can simply wrap my functions with
a i can annotate this with with dash
code and say desk please run this
function please build a task graph for
me and it will automatically parallelize
the code that i've got this is kind of
the grip it and rip it concept
so i'll pause for a quick second because
i've i've gotten a little
discombobulated i've moved a little
quickly but what i'm going to show you
next are a financial services example so
we're going to run through like a credit
risk model at scale with a big
300 node cluster with a couple terabytes
with a ton of ram
and then we'll i'll show you the same
similar thing on the gpu setup where
we'll have a local gpu in the remote gpu
cluster but let me pause just in case
i've lost too many people
um desk scaling python scale up on your
machine scale out across clusters
feeling okay for the moment
all right great
so
let us look at an example
so in this case now um i want to do some
i want to do some credit risk modeling
and i'm picking this kind of as a
generic financial services example we
could also do some back testing it's a
very common operation
and in either case i want to i want a
really really big cluster and in this
case i've got lots of data and so i'm
going to go to a company called coiled
and tell them to give me a dash cluster
but that's not my only option i could
deploy desk myself on kubernetes i could
spin up a bunch of vms i could buy a
bunch of servers plug them in and pip
install desk on all of them and i would
end up the exact same thing das
installed a bunch of servers that i can
then use this is just a little python
client that gives me access to lots of
machines so it's probably faster and
easier than that but dealer's choice
so in this case i end up with this big
cluster and i've got this cluster
dashboard over here that's going to show
me what's going on so you can see in
this case i've got a couple hundred
workers i've got a lot of ram and i've
got some existing computations
and then this dashboard by the way is
just available for all clusters it's not
a that's not a quote specific thing it
is a desk feature
so i can quickly rip through this data
set and if i do things let me just make
this a little bit easier to see
hopefully that's slightly easier i don't
know
this code here das data frame read csv
we're reading in tabular time series
data when we do this it should look just
like pandas it's mapping the api
we can then implement our back testing
strategy using standard numpy code
and the only difference here between
normal numpy and das is that when we
execute this
das is lazily evaluated similar to
sparks we'll explicitly call compute
which is going to tell das to execute
our computation on the cluster
we'll then follow the pattern we'll
calculate the return for our strategy
and what we want and here we go for our
big part of the show we're going to go
ahead and execute this from instead of
150 gigs of data for one ticker symbol
we'll go ahead and kick this off for all
of the data
in our in our sample which is like 1.3
terabytes of data running our back
testing strategy
and das is going to build this task
graph and it's going to start executing
this you're going to see this happen
it's a little choppy here because of the
data volume
but das is going to churn through this
for us and when i need more workers or
if i if i want this to dynamically scale
there's a dash setting for that i can
have adaptive scaling or i can be very
explicit and say i want 500 more i want
gpus
add them to the cluster keep running i'm
the lighting some of the difficulty with
this but not much it's pretty
straightforward import task get dashed
on a cluster of machines
start running stuff and if you you'll
check your dashboard here to see how
things are running you can take a look
at your tasks if it's running too slowly
you can add more workers or you can
profile
that makes sense
all right i'll let this one continue to
run and i'm going to jump over to a gpu
cluster and hopefully my other tab is
available um could someone confirm you
can see google cloud platform vertex ai
here
no luck i think we're stuck on the
original window um but if you want to
start
sharing your screen again there should
be an option for the full desktop
instead of just the window
yeah you know i tried it's so
embarrassing uh how in year three of the
panda am i struggling to share with
teams
um
that was that was my original was the
share full screen and it failed um i
think you can see it now at least i
shared the window yeah we're on now okay
excellent so um for many many people
don't have access to gpus or
whatever your your situation is if
you're testing stuff if you're playing
around one relatively inexpensive way to
get access
to a to a decent amount of gpu power is
through through the cloud
i have a strong preference when i'm when
i'm paying for it to use gcp uh and to
use their their managed notebook
provider vertex ai so they give me
access or they'll give you access to
jupiter lab and you can pick a machine
type that's relatively modest that has
something like a tesla t4 gpu that's
relatively inexpensive and by relatively
inexpensive i mean i think the list
price here is like 37 cents per hour for
this machine um versus the same in aws
stage maker is like 75 cents and it gets
way more expensive if you pick powerful
gpus if you start going with the larger
instances the t4 is fairly modest
um so
the trade-off of that though for being
less expensive is it's it's not
necessarily that powerful um
so there's a there's a kind of open
source has has helped us a ton here and
in particular there are two projects to
thank of course one of them is going to
be das but the other is rapids so if
you're unfamiliar
rapids is from mostly from the nvidia
team and what they've done with rapids
is they've taken the same pandas numpy
numpy style interfaces and they've
ported them over to run on gpus
specifically to run on top of cuda the
standard gpu driver so this means just
like how das and the dash data frame
interface let us read csv
across clusters of machines we can do
the exact same thing now across gpus or
machines that have gpus read csv
i can do panda style operations with a
package called qdf
it looks
just like this i'll go ahead and read in
this kind of canonical big data data set
of the day the new york city taxi data
set i'll pick one month of data and
calculate the mean on it and this
operation i won't show you without the
gpu but would take a decent amount of
time without the gpu with the gpu it
takes just a few seconds so it's
relatively fast
now
we picked or i picked the cheaper t4 gpu
because
i didn't want to spend a lot of money
and i picked a smaller instance four
cores 16 gigs of ram because i didn't
want to spend a lot of money um this
also means then that i'm going to be
limited in what i can do
even with qdf and with the rapids tools
using them natively
and desk has a as a native integration
with rapids so what this means is i'm
going to show you my little client
i'll show you my client here oh come on
come on live demo hell here uh
what i can do with daf is i can i can
use the integration between das and
rapids to create a local cuda cluster
and what this would have shown you
is the fact that now i can use if i had
multiple gpus on this machine i can use
all of those gpu cards directly with
desk so now in this and luckily the code
has been executed so i can show you but
i can edit that line of code and say
instead of reading in just one month of
data i'm going to read in the entire
year i'm going to go 12 times as much
data this would take significantly
longer in fact if i ran this on
this this four core 16 gig instance
this line of code would crash on this
small instance i could vertically scale
that'd be one option and spend more
money on compute or i could import das
qdf create my da my local das cluster
and now i can run this and das will be
very nice about spilling to disk
utilizing all the cores on the local
machine using all the gpu cores
and it will complete in a couple of
minutes so for the for this you know the
average python user out there
if you're stuck on fixed hardware even
if that hardware has a gpu das can be a
really cost effective way of scaling
your workloads on that single machine
will scale up very nicely which will
save you money
and then when it's time if you all of a
sudden say well you know what i'm
willing to spend a little bit of money i
just don't want this to run in three
minutes i want this to run in 30 seconds
i want to set how long this takes to run
then you go get yourself a dash cluster
and you can do this with services like
coiled or by installing desk yourself
and ask give me 50 instances with gpu
workers on them and then go ahead and
run this exact same computation and now
it will take 13 seconds instead of three
minutes and if i can get this down to
almost as fast as i'd like it just by
adding more workers to the machines if
that makes sense
so i'll pause there we're coming up i
think i said i do this in 15 minutes i'm
relatively close i've got some closing
slides on
deployment uh to show you and i i'm per
like divine desk law i also have to show
you the dashboard just a little bit more
as it's starting to rip through
um we'll see if i got this is through my
ten workers yeah
here we go yeah really really good
question i think one of the clear
advantages i see here on pi spark is the
whole gpu processing capabilities with
rapids right on
right like so pi spark does
parallelization but this does it on the
gpu as well right
yeah and i disagree that i well i guess
i should say i'm being argumentative i'd
be very curious to learn more about how
well you've worked with pi spark on on
gp on on the gpu
um we tend to hear a lot of struggles
there
yes i haven't done any kind of gpu by
spark yet but this this seems like a way
to do this right
it's a natural evolution to that
yeah it is it is in most most of our
most the desk use cases like most of the
the spark use cases and maybe most array
use cases are still cpu machines but i
show the gpu stuff it's a little sexier
and exciting um and and it does there is
an explicit integration or a native
integration with with the rapid suite of
tools which is the kind of pi data entry
point for most people
granted again most actually for most gpu
users so if you segment out like if
you're someone using a gpu and you know
python you're probably familiar with
rapids and das is a nice way to scale
rapids especially on a single machine
that might have more than one gpu card
but i suspect most people are probably
not using gpus most of the time right
yeah sorry i kind of barnstormed through
that question i apologize um
let me let me wrap this up then um with
just a quick word on deployment so i'll
jump back into slideshow mode
jacob tomlinson is one of the nvidia
guys
where you can run desk remember you can
pip install it run on your local machine
if your company your organization has a
cluster hpc like slurm or something like
singularity go ahead and run desk there
you can run it on hadoop if you've still
got one of those old hadoop clusters
heck you can even run it on data brexit
but it's unsupported and it runs great
on kubernetes too you could also use a
managed service you know so you'll be
more productive
but you'll have to pay a little bit of
money
something like coil
um if you're going to install this
locally here's just some a random
smorgasbord a little python quickstart
command so you know um
you'll see things like this the core
idea is that you'll always end up with a
cluster object whether that's from your
slurm or pbs cluster whether you're
using the ssh tool whether you're using
yarn which would be hadoop or let's say
the helm cluster object from das
kubernetes you always end up with a
cluster object and this is really nice
so that means when you start locally
you'll always start on your local
machine almost always you'll always
prototype with a small amount of data
with the sample you'll have you'll tell
das give you this local cluster
from there you'll scale using the
cluster that you need so most of the
time you'll stay local most of the time
you'll be able to run you'll you'll be
able to switch between local development
and then scaling to a cluster even if
it's still in the development context
won't be much of a hassle it's basically
a one-line code change
and then on the
the team when you get to the team level
when you have multiple people trying to
use a cluster the typical things we'll
see
there's a service called das gateway
which is open source which is wonderful
your tool is called uh das cloud
provider and then there are commercial
tools like coiled
similar idea
hopefully coiled is the easiest but the
idea being hey here's the number of
workers i want here's how big i want
them to be here's what software
dependencies i want on them just give it
back to me as a user let me go on my way
um so to conclude right there's lots of
ways of doing high performance python in
fact actually let me grab
if you haven't read it
make sure you read
ian oswald's high performance python
book right he'll give you all the ways
of doing this
or you can just
grab yourself a cluster and go nuts
and again my apologies for the screen
sharing issues from the beginning um
that's what that's what i got happy to
show more desk examples or take
questions
thanks for the presentation this is mark
um i'd like to ask an edge case question
if the code was was written in a very
silly way meaning no respect for
common sense algorithms and data
structures horrible
runtime increase with increasing data
volumes would dusk still do the magic
so it certainly can and that's kind of
where you you to a certain extent force
your hand into probably paying someone
like us to just make sure you had an
auto scaling cluster that kept coming up
um you will run into common if you if
you did that on a fixed size cluster the
scheduler would probably start to
deadlock at some point it would get
overwhelmed um the dash scheduler is
kind of similar to like the hadoop name
node but this this is where like you
know full sales pitch we wouldn't
necessarily advise you in this path um
but using using some sort of auto
scaling cluster yeah your code can be
ugly
the cluster will say oh gosh i need more
workers as long as your cloud account
will provision them it'll grab them
not a best practice but very doable
okay okay so you're you're saying if the
code is complete nonsensical from a
runtime point of view
a lot of improvement possible
you can still
fall through it with with dusk
yeah just just like you could run it it
if you runs locally on some sort of
subset i mean it
then it's going to run the desk is
python it's going to run on a cluster
and you'll get the benefit of all the
cores across all of those machines
so in the event that yeah it's really an
efficient code it's smelly it's terrible
but you can keep you can keep adding
machines
that's also maybe where you'd want some
cost control and some other things in
place to say gosh
whoever that person is running that
don't let them exceed x and at a certain
point of time start killing some of
their workers and you know maybe
handicap them a little bit in terms of
what they're about to do those types of
cost control mechanisms
team control if you will
are good things to have
another pitch for coil because we have
those types of features
but generally speaking we would say hey
you should probably maybe take a das
class talk to a desk expert
work with a consulting partner something
like that to improve your code you know
of course
okay sounds good thank you
thank you mark for the questions
anyone else we still got
several more minutes to ask questions
if not
um
i mean uh guys you you really have uh
don't have to rush it to be honest
you do have plenty of time um
because our session
[Music]
you know runs through 8 30. um uh i
thought we were until eight i apologize
no worries um
yeah but um but really really great uh
um
uh technology and open source uh you
know um
app you know packages every everyone can
try along and um
really really awesome uh demo um
because we encourage such of you know a
demo in our uh presentations right
because uh even in our lighting talks um
you know uh whenever you got a uh even a
really small project that you want to
try out using either
jupiter notebook or
pie chart you can always show it in in
any of your presentation get this
you know platform in our event
um this is this is all
uh you know encouraged and very very um
you know making a lot of uh
good conversations to start with right
so
um
okay i saw some comments from the chat
matthieu mori uh said uh someone did not
pray
to the democrats
yeah oh
thanks for the presentation
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good one
uh and mark also thanks uh a lot for the
task presentation uh really
uh insightful and uh
maybe
you know give it a try right
and um
uh
anyone has any comments please
please uh feel free to admit yourself
i think drove you have someone something
you want to say
i think that as opposed to the comment i
think it was a great presentation guys i
i wish we we had communicated earlier
around the timelines
we probably could have used the time uh
even further
correct
yeah
oh by the way joe do we have anyone who
would like to
um
present in the lightning talk session
if not we we can you know complete
earlier i mean it's it's it's better
you know anyone who want to present
yeah i haven't seen anything come along
but i would love to hear from anybody if
they have a lightning talk you're more
than welcome to
yeah
you know even with a really small piece
of um python debugging
that still works to
have a you know uh lightning talk
remember this is your platform to
communicate right
all right
we're right on eight o'clock um which
will be
the the starting point of the lining
talk but
if nobody want to present i think we'll
be fine right for this session yes
right
so what's your thought ted um anything
you want to speak up
maybe i'll just pick the question i
don't have a lightning talk or anything
like that but i can uh happily picture a
question to the group that might have a
very short uh answer it's something i
haven't thought a whole lot about
but right now we're in a place where we
have uh both a local cluster and a cloud
environment that have you know different
data on them and different technology
built against them
i imagine a lot of people or a lot of
companies at some point have found
themselves in a similar position
wondering if anyone here has uh
experiences and things that worked well
or horror stories of how do you blend a
local and cloud-based
data platform
great
can you say a little more about your
current tooling and
what you mean by on on-prem cluster
yeah so our on plan prem is uh hadoop
cluster running sparked
uh
yeah is it like cdhdp or something you
rolled your own
um
it's
mostly rolled our own okay
so and is it running on bare metal are
you running it on containers
uh bare metal
okay
then what's the cloud look like sorry
uh cloud is aws
gotcha and then you also running
spark in aws with with emr or something
that's right
okay
that's interesting setup
um
and then i guess maybe where is g are
you currently and not to ask you to
self-diagnose your problem but are you
currently experiencing problems around
data access like data that's in hdfs
first aid in s3
yeah for sure i mean we haven't even
started attacking that yet it's more of
a like hey we've got these two platforms
we should merge them sometimes i see i
see
and is there a sql layer that you guys
use is that spark sql or yeah if you
have like a snowflake or something we
don't um well
i say that we actually do have snowflake
databases we haven't put them in the
middle
okay but there's no impala or anything
there's not a lot of hive on-prem that
that users are going to try to migrate
no
interesting okay that should make it a
little bit easier um thanks for
clarifying i'll shut up for a second
yeah i mean i think yeah my goal is not
necessarily like solve our problem
exactly um there are a lot people
working on that but not me
but um more just that i think as a data
science practitioner that you know
there's a lot of benefit to either
platform and um being able to blend
across them might be really nice but i
haven't
haven't heard a whole lot from the
community of people who who have done
that and what that work environment
looks like
all right great
thank you guys
sounds like uh not a whole lot of
experience out there gary well i i mean
i i do but from the vendor perspective i
can share what people typically tell us
um
one common problem is is impermissions
with s3 data so typically like you'll do
this lift and shift from hdfs to s3 and
then users will say you know i used to
be able to via hive or whatever it was i
was able to get access to data now i
can't
um are you are you able to get you know
can you from your local machine run like
aws s3 ls and see the exact same things
when you run
a similar command hdfs from your
terminal
uh no we're not we're not hooked up to
that yet i guess
we are
yeah that's very common if you don't
have data
typically you know obvious point data
scientists aren't too effective
do they did someone tell you like hey
we're going to be setting up
impermissions and we'll give you you
know probably they probably won't want
to give you like an actual token but
they'll give you a role that you'll be
able to authenticate with and
um so yeah i guess we're at that's
probably going to happen sometime in the
next year
it's very obviously
hey we should maybe think about
emergencies right like really you know
yeah our work
you know in our situation our work
happens out of the on-prem cluster and
we have an opportunity
uh through kind of an acquisition to
move to the aws environment where
there's more like a cdp or a
standardized uh platform data platform
okay so
okay
um yeah one pattern we see a lot is to
for people to run spark on kubernetes or
on glue this is another service that
does like really fast spark clusters in
uws um but the data access is almost
always the problem versus like how to
get a compute environment
um
gotcha i
yeah it's a little strange i mean it's a
bummer they haven't they haven't given
you guys given you access to it yet um
uh yeah gosh are you able have you run
anything in aws so far like where you
bring up local data um yeah
what services have you used
um
we're in
like
um
lambdas
and s3
and
um cute what's it called the notebook
environment
sagemaker stage maker thank you
yeah well i mean one hack i showed it
with gcp but the same thing holds true
for sagemaker
also another common pattern that sucks
for users but it can is that
it will say like one of the only
services you're allowed to use is
sagemaker and then you're going to be
kind of they won't let you spin up your
own eks cluster or spin up your own
spark cluster using another service so
you'll be kind of stuck and you won't
even be able to go to ec2 directly but
within sagemaker you can vertically
scale the heck out of those machines so
they may give you a subset but you can
get some really big ones um
and then similarly like if you you know
installed ask on it you could get
similar distribute you know parallel
behavior for any code that you run
across those gpus or across all those
just get like a big x1 machine with a
zillion cores
it's kind of like a poor man's cluster
but you can you can hack your you know
if they're willing to pay you to leave
that machine up all day especially when
you go to lunch and you just don't leave
it running when you go home when you
know you're already home sure they'll
catch you if you leave it all weekend
but otherwise
you know you'd probably be okay
cool yeah thanks for the thoughts yeah
i'll shut up now for real
no no um i i think this is great um
really really
glad you know the sake you know good
bridge to um
communicate with each other
really great
um
all right um
i think we have a
come to an end to the uh
march session today uh please please
mark your calendar on our next event
date uh may the 4th
2022
and uh thanks again for everyone who
joined in today and i saw people already